-So happy to have you back.
-Oh, it's lovely to be here.
-You said this is
your favorite special to do
because you have
no fear anymore.
-Uh, yeah. No.
It's my favorite tour.
It's my favorite special.
Yeah, I have no fear.
No, I did think that.
I thought, you know,
you sort of --
You want to be better
and you want to be bigger,
but mainly you sort of
want to be more honest.
You want to get
to that point where...
You know?
And I've reached the point where
I've got old people's rights,
so I don't care.
-Oh, you have old people's
rights. Oh, officially.
-I don't care what I --
I don't if people --
'cause I'm gonna die soon.
-Right.
[ Laughter ]
-Do you know what I mean?
-Not soon, but, like, you have
less to go than you've had.
-Exactly. Yeah, Yeah.
I'm definitely closer to death
than birth.
-Yeah.
-That's a fact.
No one would argue that.
-Exactly.
So, I don't care, you know.
I've got the ultimate
get-out clause.
-You -- And you -- You use this.
-Also, I don't care, as well.
I don't care now
if people sort of
"I want to -- I want to fight"
or they want to punch me.
I don't care
about my face anymore.
Do you know what I mean?
-Oh!
-I've got nothing to -- And I
don't care if I punch them.
'Cause I don't care
if I'm in jail anymore.
'Cause no one's gonna
go after me in the shower now.
Do you know what I mean?
-That was your concern
about jail.
I was young and gorgeous,
but now...
-Right.
-Now, the big, bur--
They go in the shower,
"Go, oh, God. [Bleep] me.
Jesus Christ."
So, I'm all right.
I'm all right.
-And then they're writing
angry letters to the warden.
Like, "Jail isn't what it
was promised to be."
-Yeah.
-You do talk about aging
a lot in the special.
-Yes.
-And how it's affected
your body.
-Yeah. You're talking about
one bit in particular.
-Yeah.
-Yeah. They are pendulous now.
-They are.
And it was a shock to me.
How old you are you?
-I'm 44.
-So, yours are probably
nice and pert still.
-I mean, they're good,
but I bet if I saw
a picture of them at 34,
I'd be like, "Oh, [bleep]"
-Of course.
And mine were --
But I wasn't looking.
I wasn't checking.
So, it was a shock to me.
-Yeah.
-Do you know what I mean?
I didn't see them for 20 years.
But it was like, um,
then I went, "Oh, my God!"
Let were just -- I could
take down ostriches with mine.
You know what I mean?
Honestly.
-Yeah, and so it caught you
off guard.
It wasn't sort of gradual.
-No.
-No, I discovered it
in the bath.
I talk about this
in the show.
'Cause I -- Yeah.
They were floating,
and it was a shock to me.
-Yeah.
The other thing --
Well, you know,
I have a 2 year old.
And then, you know,
when you see
what they look like at the
start,
that's when you really realize
how bad yours have gone.
-Yeah.
I don't -- I haven't got a baby.
-And I don't remember mine at 2.
-Yeah.
And you certainly
don't want to agree with me,
'cause then I'd be like,
"Whose did you see?"
-Hold on, though. Don't they --
They're not even there.
Don't they drop?
-There's enough there to be
like, "Mine are a nightmare."
Compared to these.
-Yeah.
And now they're just --
-Like something that you'd see
in a butcher's bin.
[ Laughter ]
-You obviously
have to go to a doctor.
Is your doctor familiar with you
as a celebrity?
-Oh, that's the other thing.
How old are you?
You're 42, aren't you?
-44. Yeah.
-44. So you don't even have --
don't even to have the finger --
-No.
I've had like
five or six years of that.
-Really?
-Which is awkward.
-So, it's annual?
-It's -- Yeah, yeah.
[ Laughs ]
-Well, I had heard --
-You could say that.
-I had heard 40,
and I went to my doctor,
and I was like --
I was braced for it.
And they said, "No, it's not 40.
Now it's, like, 50."
-You were keen.
-I was like,
"Let's get it over with."
-You were saying, "I'm 50."
Come on!
-I lied, and they were like --
They made me take out my
driver's license.
They're like,
"Come back in ten years!"
-Go away, Mr. Meyers.
-We get this a lot.
-We're not falling
for that again.
-No, but, I mean,
it's still the finger,
and it's always awkward.
And there's a thing -- I don't
know if you have it here.
The doctor say,
"Can I give you a rectal...?"
I go, "Yeah, yeah.
Just do it," right?
And they say,
"Would you like a chaperon?"
In case they're a pervert,
you have a --
-Oh!
-Like, someone come in.
I go, "No! That'd be worse.
It's bad enough you having
your finger up me ass.
Now you got a mate watching.
Definitely not."
That's just weird, isn't it?
It's just weird.
And it's still --
And I have a --
Listen, we're all adults,
and I'm nervous.
And I make a joke about it
to sort of --
'Cause I think it's awkward
for him, as well...
-Of course.
-...to stick his --
But once, right, it was like --
It was the first time
I had it done.
To break the ice, he said --
He said,
"Big fan of 'The Office.'"
[ Laughter ]
-I went, "Oh, thank you
very much."
[ Laughter ]
-That's great.
-Oh, God. Oh.
Oh, my word.